Michel canevette pour l'Union centriste
pour 6
minutes bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
notre collègue Bernard delcro a tout à
l'heure démontré la ligne de notre
groupe de l'Union centriste je dirais
une position constructive mais exigeante
et tout au long de l'examen de ce projet
de lo de finance nous nous tiendrons à
cela parce qu'il est nécessaire de
rétablir les finances de notre pays
alors si l'on regarde d'abord au niveau
de la croissance on peut donner crédit
au gouvernement en 2023 il avait été
affiché une ambition d'1 % de croissance
ce sera tenu et nous disons que pour
2024 les 1,4 % constituent une ambition
réelle et c'est bien d'avoir de
l'ambition pour l'économie française et
donc nous soutenons totalement cette
ambition alors simplement il nous faut
DS à prés nous rendre compte quand même
de la situation réelle des finances
publiques dans notre pays nous avons
examiné le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale mardi dernier ici
au Sénat je rappelle que pour 2023 ce
sont 8,8 milliards de déficit de la
branche de la sécurité sociale 10,7
milliards en 2024 et 17 milliards et
demi en 2027 c'est dire l'effort qu'il y
a à faire pour que nous retrouvions un
équilibre de nos finances de la
protection sociale dans notre pays et
malgré ces déficit on perçoit quand même
de nombreuses euh je dirais
insatisfaction dans parmi les les
personnels et tous les acteurs de de la
protection sociale dans notre pays pour
ce qui concerne l'état la situation 2024
sera particulièrement grave d'abord
parce que nous aurons à emprunter 285
milliards sur les marchés financiers
c'est un montant tout à fait colossal et
après après 172 milliards de déficit
prévus cette année l'année prochaine
nous nous attendrons encore à 145
milliards de déficit dire le chemin et
cela a été largement évoqué par
rapporteur général dans son propos à
parcourir pour revenir à l'indispensable
équilibre des des finances publiques je
dirais que la Commission européenne
cette semaine nous a mise dans la bande
des quatre et nous sommes d'ailleurs le
plus grand pays de la bande des qu c'est
quoi la bande des qu la bande des qu
c'est avec la Belgique la Croatie et la
Finlande les quatre pays de l'Union
européenne où la croissance des dépenses
est la plus importante cela n'est pas
acceptable nous sommes encore dans la
bande des qu dans la bande des qu avec
la Belgique Malte et la Slovaquie pour
ce qui concerne le plus fort déficit par
rapport au PIB cela non plus n'est pas
acceptable et vous pensez bien qu'il
nous faut resta rapidement l'équilibre
de nos finances publiques d'autant plus
qu'il y a un certain nombre de signaux
d'alerte qui doivent nous rendre très
attentif alors pour ce qui concerne le
chômage d'abord une légère remontée du
taux du chômage mais nous disons que la
réforme qui a été engagé par le
gouvernement pour France travail doit
nous conduire justement à apporter un
certain nombre de réponses en ce sens et
nous la soutenons bien entendu mais nous
ne devons pas nous arrêter là car le
retour à l'emploi de nos concitoyens
doit demeurer un objectif
impératif cela a été dit aussi tout à
l'heure notamment par Pascal
Savoldelli la situation de la pauvreté
dans notre pays nous préoccupe oui il y
a une part croissante de la population
qui vit sous le seuil de pauvreté et les
associations caritatives nous alertent
régulièrement sur l'augmentation des
besoins à la matière ceci doit nous
conduire je crois à ce que dans l'action
publique les actions de solidarité soit
véritablement ciblé vers ceux qui en ont
besoin il ne faut pas mettre en place
des mesures généralisées mais bien dans
chaque politique mettre en place des
mesures ciblées sur les populations les
les plus en difficulté puis autre
élément extrêmement préoccupant c'est la
situation du logement le logement c'est
quelque chose d'important tout
simplement parce que il n'y a pas
d'intégration dans la société sans un
logement il n'y a pas d'insertion
professionnelle sans logement il n'y a
pas de vie sociale sans le logement ça
veut dire qu'il faut concrètement que
nous agissions sur le logement parce que
nous le voyons bien tous tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge pour ce qui
concerne la production de logement pour
ce qui concerne la vente de logement à
présent dans notre pays et sur les
perspectives pour 2024 ça veut dire
qu'il faut que l'on mène une politique
très active nous comprenons la position
du gouvernement qui vise à réduire les
dépenses fiscales sur le sujet et nous
partageons l'idée que sur le Pinel il
faut que nous rédigions la charge pour
l'État mais il nous faut quand même
favoriser l'accession à la propriété
notamment les primau ACC accédant sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et pas
simplement sur les zones tendues pour
nous c'est un enjeu tout à fait
important car si l'on veut que demain le
parc locatif se réduise que la qu'il y
ait de la mobilité sur le parc locatif
il est nécessaire que ceux qui le
souhaitent puissent accéder au logement
et donc nous pensons que le prêt à tau
zéro est un outil intéressant pour cela
le prêt à zéro est financé par des
recettes de TVA qui permettent justement
d'améliorer la situation budgétaire de
notre pays donc n'hésitons pas à faire
en sorte
que de consacrer quelques moyens à cela
pour un retour sur investissement
ensuite qui sera tout à fait intéressant
et puis Bernard delc l'a dit tout à
l'heure les niches fiscal il faut
absolument que nous remettions un peu
d'ordre dans l'ICH fiscal monsieur le
ministre euh il est clair que c'est
quelque chose qui est difficile parce
qu'il y a des bénéficiaires des
différentes niches fiscales mais il faut
que nous ayons la volonté de réduire et
de remettre en cause ces NES fiscales
pour s pour se résumer à l'essentiel
voilà quelques considérations que nous
engageons dans la manière don le groupe
centriste engage l'examen de ce PLF
merci chers collègues monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci Monsieur le le président
et puis merci